if I may mr. slim I'd like to ask you
about Fidel Castro you had an unusual
friendship with Fidel Castro do you mean
a few times the last time was many years
ago 1 2001 what have you been thinking
about these past few days since his
death well I think that he lose the
opportunity to change Cuba in 91 I was
optimistic that it was going to happen
because if you remember in 1991 they
need to go to the special period because
the Soviet Union take out the support
that they used to get him cuz I went
there to look the to invest in the
telecom company and it looked for me
very clear that things can change
easy and it didn't happen and didn't
happen well I think what happened now I
think one of the problems was things
were getting together between u.s. and
Cuba
Fidel and advance in the government of
President Clinton and and Fidel Castro
but this action when they get down a
plane you remember I do they change
everything because it was moving
indirect in the right direction but now
that he's dead do things change again do
you see Telefonica for example sells
wireless phones in Cuba could America
Movil oh I was not telefónica was the
one that they get to cover and we were
looking at and it was a Mexican group
that they thought - Telecom Italia now
alright but what I would like to know is
do you now see an opportunity to expand
into Cuba when it opened we are
interested by sure but it's not open
enough yet
no the only countries were not this in
in Cuba Bolivia Venezuela and some
countries are so many countries of the
Caribbean but we are everywhere in in
Latin America will you think about
attending Castro's funeral excuse me
would you attend his funeral no no no
close oh well I was there the last time
2001 so it's been quite a while yes I
well I went for this
like two years ago three years but like
a tourist